hey guys Pete here Netflix just dropped
a new trailer with the date announcement
for dark season 3 the release state is
what many fans had guessed June 27th
2020 the date of the apocalypse
I'm gonna break down this trailer
scene-by-scene and that will contain a
lot of spoilers about everything that
happened in the first two seasons of
dark if you're not caught up with the
series this video isn't for you consider
yourself warned the trailer opens with a
hand operating a device of some sort I'm
not sure what you can say about this
except that it looks old it has an
analogue feel to it and it's something
we haven't seen before that cuts to a
shot of the black blob of the god
particle from below since this doesn't
look like atoms layer under the church
this is probably the powerplant
post-apocalypse
the Dark Matter doesn't stabilize like
we normally see it do before someone
travels through it instead the bottom
opens up and we can see this glowing
energy inside this could be related to
the alternate world or even when it was
first created it could also be tied to
whatever atom is doing at the end of the
trailer which we'll get to
and the voice over we hear atoms say you
have many questions with a quick shot of
alt Marta arriving in the con walthaus
at the end of season 2 atom continues
shall we begin the next shot is the
destroyed power plant from a distance
the containment walls are visible so
this is sometime after 2020 but you
can't make out much more after that we
get our first look at a new character
that we'll see throughout the trailer
he's walking through atoms study
carrying a lantern similar to the one
that we saw Jonas carry into the caves
when he went to 1921 his clothing looks
to be of that same time period and he
has a scar above his lip the actor's
name is Jacob Diehl and his father in
real life Hans Diehl plays what I assume
is the older version of him next we
watch as he Onis materializes I don't
know there's a cloud of color that comes
together and then he's there I think
this is him travelling with alt Martha's
device because of a shot of Claudia
we'll see later and the voiceover he
says why am I here where are we going
which could certainly be him talking to
alt Marta when they arrive in her war
old there's a shot of him running
through the woods backwards or at least
it's playing in Reverse
and older shots of him waking up in his
room and touching held his hand through
the wormhole under the church we see the
new character again and he's joined by a
boy in an old man it's dark in the room
they're all dressed the same and they're
all carrying lanterns we get individual
looks at them as Adam says everything in
life occurs in cycles but this time it
will be the last cycle this all feeds
into my thinking that this is the same
character at three different points in
their life and I tend to think it's a
brand new character rather than someone
we already know they all have the same
scar which ties them together and at
least in the trailer they appear to be
eerily familiar with each other and the
middle one seems to be the leader or the
most active with the other two looking
pretty passive when we see them it's
almost like they're following him around
and they all work together as one we
watched as the middle one throws his
lantern at the followed the damn
painting on the wall that cuts to a shot
of the letter that young Noah gave
stranger yonus in the season 2 finale
where it's on fire remember this is what
changed strangers path at the last
minute and convinced him that he had to
save Magnus Francisca and bartosh he was
the last person we know who had the
letter and in the voiceover he asks can
we change the course of events while
there's a flash of images in that we see
alt marta wearing something around her
neck and what looks like the caves
there's a quick shot of michael suicide
and then it cuts two older noah under
the church this shot stands out in that
he's not wearing the priests clothes but
there's not a lot of other details to
work with this could be an alternate
Noah just like alternate Martha or it
could just be something from the past
that we haven't witnessed yet next
there's a recycled shot from season 2
episode 1 when stranger reveals himself
to Hannah in their kitchen then we see
what looks like the alternate Magnus
with dark hair kissing what I guess is
alt Franziska it's quick and we don't
get a lot of details here the dark hair
certainly makes it look like it's an
alternate Magnus
Franziska more or less looks the same
from what we can see after that we see
the new character watching the painting
go up in flames
Adam repeats his this not can only be
undone by destroying it entirely speech
he's talking we see the other two from
the trio smashing their lanterns and
then the whole room goes up in flames
everything looks to be on the way to
being destroyed including the family
pictures on the wall as they're watching
it burn the middle one has something in
his hand which at first I thought was
the letter on closer inspection you
can't make out what it is for sure it
looks like an envelope but we can't see
any markings on it there's a quick shot
of the passage in the cave the door
opens and we see a light but we can't
see who's holding it that cuts to a new
shot of stranger yonus wearing clothes
we've never seen him in this is most
likely after he travelled back in time
at the end of season two after that we
see the creepy trio outside the church
for the first time the middle one is
saying something to midal cloudy is
secretary from the power plant she's
from the 80s which links them to
visiting that time at least then there's
some really interesting shots the first
one is at the lake where we see a female
with dark hair from behind
smashing someone repeatedly with a rock
it makes you think of Ulrich trying to
kill young Helga outside the bunker if I
had to guess who it was I would say
Hannah based off the hair color since
there isn't anything else we can see
then we see middle cloudy a traveling
with the time machine that alt Marta had
she's got different clothes and it looks
like Charlotte is standing in front of
her I mean Charlotte had to go somewhere
and where they're at looks
post-apocalyptic you can't tell who it
is it looks like a woman to me and I
think Charlotte's the best guess but it
could be anyone as I mentioned before
when she travels it reminded me of the
earlier shot of Jonas materializing
there are these golden lights around her
and we saw those in the Yona scene as
well that cuts to a shot of a young
Elizabeth who has some blood on her face
she looks like she could be in the caves
or possibly the bunker and the screen
lights up some so she might be watching
someone travel she looks a bit older I'm
not sure if that's an indication that
this is in the near future or if it's
just the fact that child actors grow up
so fast then we see the new characters
attacking what looks like burned oppler
in his wheelchair at home this could be
related to the shot of them in the 80s
with Claudia secretary because we know
Byrne was in his wheelchair at that
time the next shot is hard to make out
but I think it's an older Helga hitting
someone or it could be the oldest of the
trio since older Helga is dead there are
a few close-up shots of the trio bathed
in a red flashing light as if they
weren't creepy enough already
I'm not sure where they are here but it
cuts to another shot of the god particle
at the power plant then we hear Marta
say it's all true
- which another woman responds you'll
understand that all when it's time to
understand this might be middle
Claudia's voice as it sounds familiar
but I can't tell for sure Marta is
wearing a familiar yellow raincoat like
young Jonas wore around in the beginning
of his story she has tears in her eyes
and the footage is playing in Reverse
making it look like she's moving away
from the viewer as the tea rolls up her
cheek there's a painting behind her that
looks like Adam and Eve from the season
three badges that were posted on
Instagram besides that it looks like
Adams lair only there was no painting
like that there so this could very well
be an alternate version of the area
under the church the trailer ends with
Adam doing something with the god
particle at the power plant he flips the
switch or perhaps the device we saw at
the beginning of the trailer the black
blob looks more chaotic and unstable
than normal and it's spinning kind of
picking up speed at the end it
compresses to a bright light and then
that cuts to the closing titles it looks
like he could be destroying it but we'll
have to wait and see the closing title
tells us the final cycle begins and then
that changes to ends and then they give
us the date of the apocalypse we hear
someone say tick tock tock tick and then
just talk so it's a pretty good trailer
there's quite a lot of new stuff the
most interesting thing is this trio of
new characters we saw in the casting
announcements last year that there would
be a father and son a real-life father
and son in season 3 and I just get a
feeling from this that these are brand
new characters they walk around with the
sense of authority and it makes things
kind of confusing dark showrunner hosted
some season 3 screenshots after the
trailer dropped to go along with some of
the mirrored photos they had posted to
announce the trailer was coming after
that and watching all the behind
seen stuff he posted I was hoping we'd
have a better idea of what was going on
in the alt world but I guess that the
first trailer you can't expect too much
in those we got the best look at the
alternate characters which is shot of
Marta and Magnus you can see that his
hair's dark he's got tattoos all over
him to mark him as an alternate there's
a picture of yonis that looks like he's
looking at his house in the alternate
world there's another one of Marta
riding the bike looking like Jonah's
wearing the raincoat and then there's a
pretty interesting one of the post
apocalypse we see there's some
destruction at the plant the trees
aren't all dead and gone yet though and
this looks more like 2020 than 2053
based on the people we see there in the
cars that's all pretty exciting
considering that we knew someone arrived
to build the restricted zone and we
never saw that period of time yet
there's also this shot of Marta with the
raincoat on in the mouth of the cave
with that police tape kind of thing
going across it the popular theory now
is that this alternate world is going to
be like almost exactly the same as the
binden we've been in for the first two
seasons only Marta is going to be doing
the things that unis did in the other
world this seems a little bit too simple
to me but we'll have to see how it plays
out there definitely teasing something
that way I mean they showed these photos
of everything flipped in the background
clearly putting the yellow jacket on
marta makes you think of the onus so
it'll be interesting to see what happens
when they arrived there claudia has
mentioned visiting the world where Jonas
doesn't exist this could certainly fit
the bill so it'll be interesting to see
what happens when he does arrive Adam
seems to be going forward with his plan
more or less less he's laid it out he
looks to be trying to destroy the world
and be interesting to see if he's
working with this trio of new characters
or if they are somehow his opposite I
got a lot of things bouncing around in
my head but I think I'll leave this
video here and then put together some
Theory videos over the next month while
we wait for the season let me know what
you thought about the trailer what
you're most excited to learn about in
season 3 and what you're surprised that
you didn't see in this because there's a
lot of characters we don't even get a
glimpse of in this trailer so let me
know in the comments what you're
thinking please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you're a fan of dark or any
of the other TV shows I cover thanks for
watching guys I'll talk to you soon